welcome to Carnegie Mellon University on
iTunes U for more visit w WC mu edu
this is a proud occasion in Carnegie
Mellon's history as we honor the memory
of the university's first PhD graduate
dr. Mao Zhi Sheng he was one of the most
important engineers of the 20th century
Molly Shang boy she da souza lorton
Danny you sure teen angel teasing she go
to the ecology me da jia jia de yuca
anyway woman such a title eats he liked
ente way she's at a shitty tuyo minda
you should do with that are going to GE
the presence of this impressive statue
of dr. mile will I am sure inspired
generations of carnegie-mellon students
to their own achievements and lead them
to emulate his technical mastery his
creativity in his dedication to the
public good we shall see Molly Shen
boarded a young Tommy since anemia
questio woman soy de shi xiang yun naman
kajal udah Jessie pinche puto hijo puta
entrancing Toshiyuki Nishida judo mais
une chanson some gorgeous Italian goons
on the den jahren su mundo jaja jajaja
su hijo Tanya dr. Mao Zhi Shan is
China's pioneer in bridge construction
and very famous scientist educator and
social activist socialization en de cada
portal hyuna channel aza Chancellor yo
to Moiraine Sedai sergey cursive on de
de de comer hello Leon charya in 1930s
he designed and constructed the first
dual use bridge cross over furious River
chintan river and was a first-ever
bridge designed by chinese themselves
and thereby paradise started the chinese
modern bridge building carnegie mellon
laguna honda shi shi y Moi's aliciarojo
sir Charle Kundun family changshu
Kendall a chisel or more solutions an
Italian Kunsan cooker teach oh yes
overseer vomit
she da de da de sangre y away carnegie
mellon tahoe you know me the days dr.
mouse spent at carnegie universe
carnegie mellon university here has laid
a solid foundation for his later
achievement and his contribution to
china bridge building engineering and
his achievement on the other hand also
brought honor to carnegie mellon home
achieve our mise en soie not tell me to
a min do-hyun the fombe TD canadian
montaje night sanguine Watterson Liam
Martin can send a courier cogency
finfish a possible war when some Guam
into the weight off with incomes entity
that summons hazard it's my hope that
this statue can become a monument for
this national hero dr. Maui shin and
this can continue to inspire all the
Chinese students overseas and as well as
in this school certainly to study hard
and to encourage them to contribute
their skills and knowledge to the growth
of our country well me achieve a muy
Generoso ya need some require typing on
the charger tianjin two million where
means agenda yo you go to 2g and two
million once again the kurta jojo jojo
jojo time zhangjiajie the unica couture
you it's also my hope that this statute
can become a kind of a bridge across in
the pacific ocean to connect chinese
people and american people can promote
friendship between two nations and
encouraged more exchanges in size
technology and promote more
collaboration